CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is a
congressional reporter for the
Washington Post
he's on Capitol Hill and joins us now
with the latest Edie good morning called
the London guys
happy Monday indeed call this hashtag
hot mess with enough blame to go around
how do you see this playing out today
the president says let's go nuclear that
that won't happen but I don't think the
government's gonna reopen either it
looks like Democrats aren't going to
budge much at all despite the Senate
Majority Leader's pledge to take up
immigration reform by at least February
8th the problem is they want it now they
want it as part of an agreement to
reopen the government or at least to be
part of the bill that keeps the
government open long term absent that
you may see maybe one or two more
Democrats vote YES today but it won't be
enough to advance the bills so ad I mean
is it almost always does it this is just
going to come down to someone blinking
at some point yeah I mean what's that
all Billy Joel song a matter of trust
that's the issue here they don't trust
each other the majority leader may say
he's going to do something but Democrats
having dealt with him for several years
now know that the Republicans can just
pull the wool over their eyes and and
and reverse course at some other point
in the coming day so they don't want to
commit to anything unless it's a vote
right now or unless there's some other
ironclad agreement that is that is
worked out between him
House Speaker Ryan and the president who
of course remains so difficult to pin
down in all of this so you've been
reporting about members of both parties
in senator collins office over the
weekend what were they talking about
what's the formation of that deal yeah
Susan Collins the Republican senator
from Maine brought together a total of
19 senators from both parties on Friday
Saturday and Sunday to try to talk about
this they didn't get anywhere really is
one of the attendees told me it was a
good group we had some good ideas we may
be helpful in a substantive agreement
down the road but simply put they just
couldn't do it this time
Collins hosted similar meetings back in
2013 to try to break the last government
shutdown so there's some hope that
bringing together a big block about
one-fifth of the Senate then maybe they
can convince their colleagues to move
ahead but so far at least it doesn't
look like they're able to do that is
there anything any truth to what Senator
Lindsey Graham said essentially blaming
Stephen Miller a young White House aide
of holding this whole thing hostage
if you were if you were to ask members
of both parties he's the guy that they
blame for this yes because he's the one
that has kept the president far more
conservative on immigration matters than
Democrats and Republicans would like it
Oh keep good to see you thank you so
much